ايرادات مذهله لفيلمي باربي واوبنهايمر
والهضبه يشعل مواقع التواصل بالفصحى اليكم
الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
هاي
كان حقق فيلم باربي للمخرجه جريتا جرويج
ايرادات بلغت 155 مليون دولار بمجرد اطلاق
عرضه خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع في امريكا
ايرادات وصفت بالمذهله والقياسيه وجاء
خلفه من حيث حجم الايرادات التي فاقت
التوقعات ايضا فيلم اوبن هايبر للمخرج
كريستوفر نولاند محققا 80 مليون ونصف
المليون دولار في دور العرض المحليه ما
اعطى املا بانتعاش كبير للاستوديوهات ودور
العرض في امريكا ويحقق فيلم باربي تفاعلا
واسعا عالميا منذ اطلاق عروضه حيث يجتاح
اللون الوردي منصات التواصل وتدور احداثه
حول الدميه الشهيره التي ظهرت قبل 60 عاما
وتجسد شخصيتها في الفيلم
اما فيلم اوبن هايمر فتدور احداثه حول
السيره الذاتيه للعالم الامريكي
والذي اصبح يعرف بوالد القنبله الذريه
ويجسد شخصيته في الفيلم كيليان
[موسيقى]
سينمائيا ايضا حقق الاعلان الترويجي لفيلم
محمد هنيدي الجديد مرعي البريمو نوعا من
التفاعل على منصات التواصل في مصر وسيكون
على قائمه الافلام المصريه المتنافسه على
الفوز بايرادات دور العرض في المحروسه
والعالم العربي خلال شهر اب اغسطس واصبح
مؤكدا دخول فيلم الزيرو من بطوله محمد
رمضان هذه المنافسات مطلع الشهر المقبل
[موسيقى]
ومن السينما المصريه الى الغناء واصدار
غناء جديد لعمرو دياب حقق تفاعلا كبيرا
على منصات التواصل في مصر والعالم العربي
فالهضبه غنى لاول مره بالفصحى منشدا
ابياتا شهيره لابن زيدون من الحان عزيز
الشافعي
نا كما كان محبو الفنانين المصريين روبي
واحمد سعد الاسبوع الماضي على موعد وجمع
بينهما في اغنيه يا ليالي
يا ليالي اعذر
الغالي على القمر
واحيا سعد حفله المنتظر في مهرجان قرطاج
الدولي في تونس بعد الجدل التي عكر اجواء
حفله الاخير في بنزرت
[موسيقى]
وعلى سيره المهرجانات فاجات تامر حسني
جمهوره في مهرجان العلمين بدخول مبتكر على
طريقه الابطال الخارقين في اطلاله
المستوحاه من احدث افلامه تاج
[موسيقى]
واخيرا اعلن المتحدث باسم لينسي لوهان
وزوجها رجل الاعمال الاماراتي الامريكي
بدر شماس انه ما رزق بمولودهما الاول لؤي
وذلك بعد عام على اعلان زواجهما رسميا